events are taking place in many parts of
the world to mark International Women's
Day here in Berlin thousands have been
marching in support of women's rights
for the first time it's been declared a
public holiday in the capital the only
part of Germany to do so the marchers in
protest against sexism and gender
discrimination around the world dwz
melinda crane is covering that one of
those rallies in Berlin let's join her
and find out how things are going
welcome Melinda tell us about the
turnout tell us what's expected to
happen today turnouts good the police
have just done a count and say they're
at 7,500 but the crowds been expanding
rapidly over the past hour the March has
just now gotten underway and it will be
going on for about another hour hour and
a half and winding up not too far from
here we're at 5 o'clock our time there
will be a global shout from this crowd a
shout of rage in protest and in demand
that that gender equality move faster
and the crowd is very enthusiastic I
just made my way through it on the way
to our camera position a lot of young
women but not only all ages represented
families a lot of men and a lot of
enthusiasm and when does Germany stand
and in the campaign for gender equality
there's a lot of room for improvement
various studies give different numbers
but for example the World Bank says
Germany is somewhere around thirty first
place
in the world rankings but behind a
number of other countries that are less
wealthy than this one and if you look at
specific aspects of gender equality the
picture is quite uneven for example
there's a wage gap here of Twelver 21
percent in other words men earning on
average 21 percent more than women for
comparable work
and that puts Germany quite low in
Europe only Estonia and Austria are
behind it so it's it's quite doing quite
poorly on that score or if we look at
the degree to which women have broken
through the so-called glass ceiling when
it comes to two top positions in the
private sector in there's now a quota in
Germany for supervisory boards of large
companies so that they are slowly
getting to the 30% quota that is
required of women on supervisory boards
but it's had very little effect so far
on operational management their women
are still less than 10% of the actual
operational management so lots of room
for improvement there as well and other
theories as to why Germany is so far
behind given its it's generally
progressive reputation well for a long
time and given the fact that the most
powerful woman in the world is the head
of the German government
a supreme irony if you will but there
the theories going back to the period of
the Cold War were that West Germany was
very eager to maintain conservative
social traditions putting women
essentially in the kitchen and in the
nursery part partly in contrast to
eastern Germany where women's rights
were very very strong but of course that
was 30 years ago that the Berlin Wall
fell so there has been changed since
then
but it has been slow for example
throughout many parts of Germany it's
hard for families to find a kindergarten
place even to this day many schools are
going until lunchtime and then release
the children sending them home with the
expectation that there will be a mother
at home to provide a warm lunch all of
that is changing but it's changing very
slowly this government has made some of
those issues priorities but as I say
there's still a lot of work to be done
well in decried and
Oberlin for now thank you